[Music]  we gonna wonder women let's no further  than the ladies as excite dumped me Mila  Kunis and Kate McKinnon they were the  duo that I never knew I needed when I  saw this movie so I knew I needed them  way years ago I'll tell you anything  that you want to know if Audrey shaves  between for boobs Morgan kissed her  cousin I didn't know once my cousin Mila  and Kate became the ultimate BFFs on  this set and in the film they are  definite goals burning bad exes stuff  together even comfortable enough to  snort while laughing add lots of humor  lots of crazy action sequences do you  think you're making good spy no no I'm  very loud and so like I feel like I  wouldn't be able to like sneak into  places very well but I said jeez it's  you know your magnetic and it serves you  in your role as film star but I'm sorry  you would just Sparkle to lovely and to  brightly from across the street you are  incredible and I want you to own it  [Applause]  you